[Música]
es momento de hablar de ciencia y
tecnología en france24
soy valentina torre sánchez y los
acompaño desde casa debido a la
situación causada por la pandemia de
kobe 19 iniciamos este espacio hablando
del plan que tiene la compañía
hongkonesa hanson robotics de crear
miles de robots durante 2021 recordemos
que ellos son los responsables de sofía
esta robot humanoide que es capaz de
sostener conversaciones y tiene
múltiples expresiones faciales
precisamente serían miles de sofía las
que se produzcan durante este año
estamos produciendo en masa a sofía esta
es sofía número 24 y muchos de mis
robots anteriores eran producidos a mano
sin embargo hemos empezado a escalar la
producción de sofía para hacer cientos y
miles de unidades
usarlas como base para muchos otros
personajes
de acuerdo con la compañía los robots
como sofía serán clave para acompañar a
las personas mientras que se encuentran
en aislamiento forzado por la pandemia
pero también pueden llevar a cabo
funciones básicas como tomar la
temperatura por lo que podrían
desempeñarse en muchos campos incluso
como auxiliares de vuelo
los robots sociales como yo podemos
ayudar a cuidar de enfermos o adultos
mayores de muchas formas puede ayudar a
que se comuniquen suministrar terapias y
proveer estimulación social incluso en
situaciones difíciles
ellos emulan la forma humana la figura y
las interacciones y pueden ser útiles en
estos momentos en que las personas están
terriblemente solo aisladas socialmente
la gente tiene que estar aislada de los
demás porque son peligrosos pero estos
robots pueden mantener a las personas
seguras y proveer la calidez humana
la conexión humana como una herramienta
de telepresencia aceptable presente de
parís continuamos hablando de joven
ahora nos centramos en cómo ha
disminuido la desconfianza de las
personas en las vacunas contra el virus
esto es lo que asegura la más reciente
encuesta de la compañía ipsos que indica
que el éxito que han tenido las campañas
de inmunización que hasta el momento ya
se realizan en decenas de países ha sido
responsable de que aumente la confianza
a medida que comenzamos a ver millones
de personas vacunadas y lo que vimos en
los datos día a día durante 2020 que
equipos alrededor del mundo se
apresuraron a producir las vacunas
vimos una disminución en la confianza de
las vacunas de las encuestas realizadas
alrededor del globo
hemos visto desde diciembre que
iniciaron los programas de vacunación
que muchas más personas dicen que se
aplicarán la vacuna porque claro si
saben que en su país 6 millones de
personas la han recibido y no ha habido
historias de efectos secundarios masivos
estamos empezando a ver aumentos
considerables en la proporción de
personas que dicen que se le aplicarían
sin embargo aún hay diferencias
regionales y nacionales masivas en la
proporción de quienes se la aplicarían
que el sondeo fue real
en 15 países en los que hay más
disposición para aplicarse la vacuna son
precisamente brasil reino unido y china
y en los que persiste el mayor
porcentaje de desconfianza son rusia
sudáfrica y francia de acuerdo con la
compañía del uso de redes sociales tiene
una alta influencia en si las personas
aceptarían vacunarse pues en estas
plataformas es donde se propaga la mayor
cantidad de mensajes que desalientan la
inmunización soy su mitad sabe que las
redes sociales tienen un papel clave en
todo esto porque si estás preocupado por
la zona o incluso eres susceptible a
teorías conspirativas
estamos encontrando que eso es mayor
entre personas que usan plataformas como
youtube o facebook para informar
asimismo los expertos aseguran que en
otros casos lo que deja ver el fenómeno
de la vacunación es la profunda
polarización que existe entre las
sociedades pues en muchas ocasiones la
decisión de aplicarse o no una vacuna
depende de los líderes políticos o
sociales que lo recomienden y no de los
expertos sanitarios
y veo el cobit como una gran oportunidad
para el público para que los gobiernos
reconstruyen la confianza que está
altamente diezmada whittingham aurich es
decir si podemos salir de esto con que
la gente tenga una apreciación diferente
de sus gobiernos podríamos cambiar todo
el panorama de la confianza si sienten
que han sido traicionados o golpeados
tendremos que empezar decir que
cambiamos de tema y vamos a kenia donde
david gato y mouses qinghua crearon un
brazo robótico que es operado usando
señales cerebrales de mayor multicaja
el brazo vio robótico usa las señales
cerebrales y amplifica las filtra y las
convierte en corriente eléctrica
preferente
pero estás te den combaten esta
corriente se envía al circuito del robot
lo que significa que los pensamientos
del usuario se pueden convertir en
movimiento del brazo robótico
el brazo está hecho de madera reciclada
y otros materiales y se mueve vertical y
horizontalmente lo que facilita la
operación de las personas con
discapacidades
finalizamos esta crónica con las
imágenes de spacex que rompió un nuevo
récord al lanzar 143 satélites en un
solo cohete se trata de la misión
transportar one con la que se inició el
nuevo programa de la compañía que busca
reducir costos de envío al espacio para
sus clientes
en otras palabras varias empresas hacen
un viaje compartido y envían pequeños
satélites en lugar de comprar un cohete
completo por un precio mucho mayor el
envío de 200 kilos cuesta un millón de
dólares es decir unos cinco mil dólares
por kilo en esta ocasión fueron enviados
133 satélites pequeños variados entre
ellos un contenedor lleno de restos
humanos cremados de la empresa celeste
llegamos al final de este espacio a
ustedes gracias por su compañía este y
otros programas pueden repetirlos en
nuestra web france24 puntocom
[Música]